[Musique]
l'affairé et je me fais des mails
enfants après avons assez de licenciés à
travers 120 nouvelles attentes de
spécialisé dans les problématiques
phares est gentillette j'ai été nommée
tiana j'adore me lancer un nouveau défi
nature de paris ça va était sûrement le
plus beau est réalisé je voulais arrêter
[Musique]
une émission de
même chez vous vous en pensez ce que
vous voulez serait intéressant d'avoir
des sondages mais on l'est on les a
perdus durant l'année prochaine ce
budget mais voilà sans langue de bois on
est en train de tout ouvrir après les
miss france maintenant on a droit doit
d'être en couple aurait dans les enfants
des tatouages d'être mariée
mère de presse que merci beaucoup non
résidents est ce que est ce que ça pour
toi ça va trop loin si tu as dix rames
de bois évidemment je vais me prendre
les pieds dans le tapis mais comment on
peut accepter qu'une fille qui fait
moins d'un mètre soixante dix ne puisse
pas concourir à miss france et qu'une
fille cabine top avant
ça
c'est pas dégueulasse et dégueulasse il
manie si
je suis leur famille ils seront
accompagnés ce qu'il a dit est ce que
tout le monde comprend que dalle sous la
contrainte je suis content qu'elle ait
réussi sa transformation et tous mes
mails mais pour moi yengo il ya des
critères de sélection et les critères
gestion devient complètement et non mais
délieront mais j'entends c'est en
général et tu vas y être dans l'avenir
écoutons non mais c'est pas sarko tu
peux écouter les morceaux qui font les
femmes qui font moins d'un mètre 70
c'est pas des femmes qui osent qui font
des trucs qui ont une vie hyper
compliqué en france et qui doivent mener
des combats tout au cours de leur vie
rythmée femme transgenre là c'est un
exemple je tourne et ancien d unique et
d'être en jambes je dis tu dis oui mais
si les femmes les femmes qui fument
moins d'un mètre soixante dix sept plats
les plus indigentes joueur peut parier
là qu'est ce que tu distribues pas du
tout les femmes transgenres elle est
magnifique elle voulait elle voulait se
consommer elle l'a réussi et bravo et
bravo à tous ceux qui veulent lui faire
regretter mais en mai 3 et je trouve que
comme on peut imposer des critères alors
qu'il ya des critères car on veut cet
intérim à dire est ce que je peux
comprendre c'est que effectivement quand
tu es un changement d'état civil on est
passé de monsieur madame c'est une femme
ya pas de prôner madère mais forcément
quand a été monsieur tu as plus de
chances de faire plus d'un mètre
soixante dix que quand tu étais madame à
la base c'est même pas ce qu'il sait sur
mais moi juste le contre argument que
j'essaie de donner
oui c'est que quand les femmes qui font
moins d'un mètre soixante dix qui ne
peuvent pas participer à ce concours l
on désire deux femmes deux françaises
elles ne sont pas victimes de
discrimination elles n'ont pas désiré ne
sont pas en marge de la société les
joueurs de détails on peut en parler au
nom de soixante dix quand ils ont plus
de 68 elle a pas de problèmes dans sa
vie devient la mi-temps
les genres elles sont stigmatisées elles
sont rejetées à lévis horrible on dit
des horreurs comme ça au dos à dos une
pub ou je sais pas quoi j'aimais
bien que pour l'exemplarité moi je
trouve que c'est bien et je pense que le
comparer avec les femmes qui font moins
d'un mètre s'amuser à l'achat de 106 à
bresso andré assuré pardon mais c'est un
cap thuliez victimes de discrimination
c'est un cas totalement part ça fait
plus de dix ans qu'elle est médiatisé un
sur quatre jours la monnaie télévision
raconter sa vie elle est vraiment un cas
une jeune fille parfaitement intégrée à
ces femmes transgenres général tu dis
quand tu dis est ce que dit et vu que ce
que dit jean michel est dégueulasse mais
non il le dit de façon totalement
pragmatique c'est pas un jugement de
valeur femme karine cadenas sur les
règles qu'elle a jadis dans le dit à
l'ats jean michel il le dit à l'ats jean
michal à 16h et puis c'est dans la rue
tu vas passer dans la balle mais c'est
parce que les gens disent que tout ce
que disent les gens à la rue c'est vrai
non mais c'est alors je savais pas et
journée près mais je veux dire selon mme
et pratique la population c'est pas pour
la musique ou des céphalées je suis pour
qu'il ait plus aucun ami pierre miss
france pas l'annoncer apprentis n'y a
plus aucun critère j'ai fait
il ya plus qu acquiescer à la jean
michel sala